[Música]
llevo 11 años intentando graduarme de la
universidad
recuerdo cuando ingresé cuando tenía tan
sólo 17 años hoy ya tengo 28 y todavía
no me graduado una historia con la que
muchos se podrían sentir identificados
me cambié de carrera dos veces empecé
por ingeniería me pase a arquitectura
finalmente administración y si hay algo
más difícil que decirle a tus padres que
no te ha grabado que ese dinero y ese
tiempo se perdieron
es decir se los dos veces ciertamente la
credibilidad se empieza a perder y sin
embargo ahí estado por más de una década
intentando entender cuál es la carrera
correcta cómo puedo impactar
positivamente a las personas al mundo en
definitiva cómo puedo ser valioso y cómo
puedo ser parte del progreso al fin y al
cabo es la razón por la cual decidí
empezar a estudiar sin embargo la
sociedad se ha acostumbrado a valorar
qué tanto aportas según unos hitos muy
específicos como
de donde te gradúas te en donde
trabajaste cuánto ganas e incluso con
quien te casas y para mí ha sido muy
importante entender cómo puedo ser
valioso incluso antes de tener un título
porque si no imagínense qué hubiera
pasado todo este tiempo mientras no me
gradué
es por eso que mi propósito con esta
charla es poderles quitar ese peso
encima que juntos podamos descubrir como
ser valiosos y ser parte del progreso de
una forma más práctica que motivacional
coincidencialmente en dos días a partir
de hoy cuando me bajé de esta tarima por
fin me voy a graduar y me va a graduar
con muchas más historias que títulos y
con tres aprendizajes muy puntuales que
les quiero compartir hoy el primer
aprendizaje tiene que ver con nuestra
capacidad de intervenir las situaciones
que nos ocurren a diario seguramente en
la medida que ustedes viven su vida se
han dado cuenta de ciertas situaciones
de ciertos escenarios que creen que
podrían ser mejor que les incomodan de
cierta manera en donde identifican que
hay problemáticas al fin y al cabo el
mundo no es perfecto y es allí donde
podemos intervenir es allí donde podemos
generar cambios justamente cuando
ingresé a la universidad en mis primeros
semestres había una problemática muy
grande porque imagínense lo siguiente mi
universidad estaba de este lado y la
zona de restaurantes estaba de este otro
y en la mitad había una avenida
vehicular muy trans
y la única forma de pasar de la
universidad a la zona de restaurantes
era a través de un túnel que pasaba por
debajo de la avenida y era un túnel que
no tenía más de tres metros de ancho así
que imagínense 30.000 personas a la hora
del almuerzo decidían pasar a través de
este túnel para ir a almorzar lo cual
parecía más que un túnel un embudo eso
generaba prolongados tiempos de espera
filas larguísimas y problemas de
abastecimiento en general así que con un
grupo de amigos decidimos intervenir y
nos volvimos los domiciliarios de la
comunidad universitaria para que las
personas pudieran pedir a domicilio
comida
eventualmente empezó a crecer y gustó
así que dejamos de recibir los pedidos
por whatsapp y creamos un sitio web
llamado comida en la uv puntocom una
plataforma donde estudiantes profesores
y administrativos podían pedir comida a
cualquier lugar del campus y como éramos
estudiantes podíamos ingresar donde
quisiéramos y llevarlo inclusive
directamente al salón
más allá de ser un gran negocio porque
después de un año de hacer cientos de
pedidos nos ganamos 20 dólares que
repartimos entre nosotros más que eso
fue la posibilidad de reiterar que
intervenir lo que pasa a nuestro
alrededor tiene consecuencias muy
positivas y que trae unos beneficios muy
importantes como el hecho de dejar de
ser creadores de ideas y empezar a hacer
solucionadores de problemas porque a
decir verdad las ideas no tienen ningún
valor allí afuera cuántas veces no le
hemos escuchado una idea grandiosa a
algún amigo o algún colega o inclusive
cuántas personas no se nos acercaron a
decirnos a mí se me había ocurrido esa
idea de los domicilios antes si no hay
inversión de tiempo o de capital o de
personas una idea no puede florecer y
salir a flote es por eso que es muy
importante intervenir y ejecutarlas y
por otro lado cuando te acostumbras a
intervenir estadísticamente aumentas la
probabilidad de estar en el lugar y en
el momento correcto así que con esa idea
en mente con mis amigos empezamos a
intervenir todo tipo de situaciones
y a creer que era posible solucionar
todas las problemáticas que habíamos a
nuestro alrededor y es por eso que en un
año
creamos siete negocios esos siete
negocios fueron un rotundo éxito los
medios de comunicación se preguntaban
cómo hicieron como hicieron estos
jóvenes para crear todos estos negocios
en tan solo un año cómo hicieron para
crear un imperio en tan poco tiempo y
cómo hacían para proyectarse a ser los
nuevos empresarios de colombia
realmente eso no pasó seis de esos siete
negocios quebraron quizás por falta de
experiencia por falta de foco y el
último que quedó que era comida en la u
terminó quebrando un par de veces más
adelante incluso nos vimos en una
situación en la cual nos demandaron y
nos quisieron meter a la cárcel porque
como buenos emprendedores éramos muy
malos empresarios hoy comida en la u
ahora se llama en lado porque hace más
que comida hace tutorías en la u torneos
en la un voluntariado en la uv y está
transformando la vida universitaria en
más de siete países
pero llegó la pandemia y nuestro
contexto cambió y nos vimos obligados a
pensar de una manera diferente porque
las problemáticas ya no eran las mismas
y es aquí donde llegó el segundo
aprendizaje y es trabaja con lo que ya
tienes porque cuando iniciamos con
comida en la uv lo único que teníamos
era hambre y un poco de actitud para
querer transformar nuestro entorno pero
en este momento teníamos un poco más de
conocimiento acerca de cómo entregar un
domicilio o cómo funciona la industria
alimenticia y nos dimos cuenta que en
medio de una pandemia las personas
tenían un alto riesgo de contagio si
salían a ser mercado que pedir un
domicilio a diario era un costo muy
elevado o que cocinar todo el tiempo en
casa era frustrante y consumida
demasiado tiempo es por eso que creamos
un negocio en tan solo una semana un
negocio que buscaba entregar productos
pre elaborados desinfectados que las
personas podían almacenar en su nevera
hasta por 45 días y que tan solo
descongelando los ya tenían una comida
preparada en tan sólo 10 minutos el solo
hecho de entregárselo a las personas en
la mano y decir
dárselo al frente empezó a crear un boom
en redes sociales y nos empezaron a
apoyar personas de una forma muy
auténtica sin ni siquiera pedírselos a
tal punto que tan sólo dos días después
de lanzar esta iniciativa los medios de
comunicación esta vez si estaban
hablando del tema y le pusimos por
nombre todos comemos puntocom se podrán
dar cuenta comida en la puntocom todos
comemos puntocom somos unos expertos
creativos en crear nombres para empresas
y este proyecto nos permitió a nosotros
entender que validar una idea rápido nos
pone en una posición muy ventajosa en el
mercado así que no sólo aparecimos en
medios sino que dos semanas después pasó
lo impensable y es que
pudimos quedar en el programa más
importante para empresas en todo el
mundo llamado white combinator donde han
estado empresas como dropbox twitch bien
incluso rápido
y para nosotros fue un logro que nunca
creímos posible por la inexperiencia que
teníamos en el tema pero como les dije
llegará el momento en el que se
acostumbren a intervenir que van a estar
en el momento y en el lugar correcto y
el hecho de que ustedes valley en una
idea rápidamente les permite ustedes
tener información suficiente para poder
mejorarla para responder realmente a una
necesidad y no que sea simplemente un
modelo creado desde su perspectiva y
desde sus opiniones mientras creamos
este negocio de todos comemos llegó el
tercer aprendizaje y creo que es el más
importante y se trata de que creer crear
realidades
yo realmente no creía que supiera más
allá de un domicilio o de temas de
alimentación algo interesante que podría
compartir con el mundo y sin embargo fue
importante entender que me había
convertido en la persona que diseñó
estas plataformas que había diseñado la
aplicación y la página web y que había
aprendido de todos los retos que tienen
las personas a la hora de interactuar
con los productos digitales y no solo
con este tipo de productos sino también
con temas mucho más comunes como su
celular ios android cómo utilizan su
computador y sin ser un experto muchas
personas me empezaron a preguntar de
charly qué aplicación crees que sería
mejor para ser más productivo o charly
qué computador te comprarías yo desde mi
inexperiencia decidía compartirles y
cómo se pueden dar cuenta pues tampoco
tenía un título para ser un experto y
poderles dar una información de valor
sin embargo mi hermano decidió creer que
eso sí tenía valor que a pesar de que yo
no era un experto ese
pasión alguien más la podría necesitar
recuerdo cuando me dijo charly esa
información es muy valiosa que para ti
sea normal quizás para otros no y me
alentó a que empezáramos a compartir
vídeos en internet y así fue empezamos a
lanzar vídeos de tips muy simples
alrededor de la tecnología y pasó lo
impensable después de tan solo cuatro
meses de subir nuestro primer vídeo el
año pasado más de tres millones de
personas empezaron a seguir lo que
teníamos por decir fue necesario ser un
poco más irracional porque racionalmente
yo nunca pensé que pudiera crear
contenido en redes sociales
racionalmente yo debía tener un título
para poder hablar de algún tema
esto para nosotros fue el aprendizaje
más grande porque nos dimos cuenta que
la cima es un lugar solitario no porque
las personas carezcan de talento sino
porque el 99 por ciento de las personas
no cree que puede lograr cosas grandes y
es por eso que en muchas ocasiones
inclusive es más fácil conquistar a esa
persona que para ti es un 10 que esa
persona que para ti es un 8 la mayoría
de personas no aspiran a lo mejor y hay
una menor competencia cuando tus sueños
son grandes
estoy más cerca de graduarme de lo que
estaba cuando inicie esta charla y estos
tres aprendizajes me permitieron a mí
entender que todo lo que está ocurriendo
en mi entorno yo lo puedo intervenir
algo tan sencillo como inclusive
empeorar ciertas situaciones en las
cuales simplemente con una actitud o un
comentario pudiera crear valor o también
que los recursos que tengo a la mano y a
mi disposición son suficientes así que
sin importar tu contexto algo puedes
hacer con lo que ya tienes pero lo más
importante es que creer en ti te pone en
una ventaja competitiva frente a la
mayoría de personas después de 11 años
de carrera más de 200 clases y más de 5
mil horas de estudio entendí que las
personas racionales se adaptan a su
entorno y no están dispuestas a
cambiarlo
pero las personas irracionales son
aquellas que están dispuestas a
intervenir que no se cuestiona en cuanto
saben sino que desde lo que tienen
deciden hacer un cambio de lo que está
ocurriendo en su entorno eso quiere
decir que el progreso está en manos de
quienes deciden ser irracionales es por
eso que si te estabas preguntando cómo
puedo ser valioso como puedo ser parte
del progreso quizás valga la pena que
hoy salgas un poco más irracional y loco
de lo que llegaste siendo y tu primer
acto de locura debería ser creer en ti
mismo o aún mejor creer en las personas
que tienes a tu alrededor así como mis
padres decidieron creer en mí a pesar de
que me cambió varias veces de carrera o
así como mis socios también creyeron en
mí y en lo que estábamos haciendo a
pesar de que quebramos en múltiples
ocasiones o así como mi hermano decidió
creer en mí más de lo que yo creía en mí
mismo porque al final crear valor y ser
parte del progreso es un proceso
colectivo
sí sí
[Música]